10 nique la france et puis ensuite tu
dis vive d'autres pays c'était origines
mais je veux dire si tu as choisi la
france c'est bien parce que tu as voulu
quitter ton pays pour venir en france
des excuses tout le monde j'ai pas fait
exprès non non je ne vis pas ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais un mois et demi de déballage
médiatique johnny depp remporte le
procès en diffamation contre son ex
compagne amber heard
est ce que l'on pensait que monsieur
depp avait preuve fiable prouvant que
mademoiselle hurd a à g avec malice la
panse du jury et amis les jurés ont voté
à l'unanimité la condamnation dans bird
à lui verser la somme de 15 millions de
dollars de dommages et intérêts déjà
c'est une grosse surprise parce qu en
fait pour les avocats de l'envahir on
pensait on pensait que c'était facile en
fait le prouver que l a pas diffamer
dire que même si elle avait porté des
coups même s'il y avait une relation
toxique en fait lui aussi porté des
coups puisque en fait c'est ce qu'avait
dit le juge en angleterre donc c'est un
vrai fiasco pour les avocats de amber
qui sont passés complètement à côté
évidemment c'est un procès qui est
complètement hors norme c'est quand même
que les temps changent donne juste une
indication dior a soutenu et l'a soutenu
jusqu'au bout puisque le parfum sauvage
on le voit encore à la télé il a
exactement dior c'est quand même une
marque d'annuler en cas des femmes c'est
une marque qui à pied féminine adore ça
et ça aurait pu tourner au vinaigre mais
c'est en plus sauvage on aurait pu se
dire il déploie sa fin et il fait la pub
pour sauvage et serait peut être pourri
cote contre dior il n'y a pas eu ça du
tout du tout marcos a donc engrangé
donné 15 millions mais en fait la juge a
ramené les 5 millions de dommages et
intérêts punitifs et six a350
c'était un peu un fiasco hier les jurés
millions d'aller saluer les raidillons
non justement c'est ce qu'elle a dit
aujourd'hui elle a dit moi j'ai comme là
je fais appel j'espère que je serai
entendu parce que comment il fait sienne
n'a pas
une deuxième soirée on dispose on les
dit de toute façon la même en faisant
appel doivent à doit donner environ
l'équivalent de 2000 euros 9 9 me
exactement neuf doit donner c'est à dire
que c'est pas
suspensif d'accord elle va pas à temps
johnny depp a été puni quand même de
deux millions de diffamation inverse le
lait j'aurais essayé de couper un petit
peu la poire en deux
[Musique]
ac world series des besoins de jénine
moreau
alors voilà c'est vrai que cette vidéo a
fait énormément parler vous êtes allés
devant le stade de france vous n'aviez
pas de billets pro vous a dit je vais
pouvoir rentrer
bonjour
giron des jets par teva retour à côté le
stade après je vois les anglais étaient
là brito sont pas rentrés koné commencé
le match est commencé pour site où tout
le monde 10 pouces moi j'ai rentré avec
au jeu rentrer par la porte c'est pas
sauter tout par la rentrée tranquille
personne n'a rien dit à personne mais
plutôt pourquoi tu as fait la vidéo a
suivi la vidéo pour mes amis tôt mais on
rigolait avec mes amis d après moi je
savais pas il ya
stade le canada c'est au stade de france
c'est ça j'ai trompé j'ai mis sur les
roses et sociaux c'est tout après quand
je rentre et je parle des papiers des
papes et je parle pour le ticket chez
pathé quinté gers est rentré je te
regretter ces propos
normalement je dis pas ça nous avait dit
ça
que je rentre il match et tout ce jeu
savamment page et comme j'ai dit et je
rentrais sur le mois çi tout il y avait
de monde sait ce que je lis bilal ça par
exemple on pourra ça porte préjudice à
tous qu'on essaie
à tout ce qu'on essaie de défendre et
c'est ça quand le drapeau bleu origine
est une histoire beaucoup de personnes
qui voient les pseudos patriotes ces
pseudo nationalistes moi j'aime la
france quand tu vas dire des propos sur
la france a touché toutes ces terrains
je sors pas de rouget de lisle jeu rock
band accusé mardi la vérité à la course
est très bon vous êtes là monsieur mais
après la réalité la réalité ces pauvres
en france je vais [ __ ] la france et ça
c'est ce qu'on voit et ça c'est ce que
vous dites merci à vous venez et un
super beau discours patriotique et tous
armés mais il traduit jamais monsieur
moi je juge de répondre à damara tabac
il n'a rien fait à chaque fois on a jeté
une question quand tu comprends le tu
comprends le lynchage oui j'ai une
question très simple pour bilal alors tu
peux me répondre juste par oui ou par
non est ce que tu es fier de vivre en
france
d'accord et donc quand tu es fier donc
ce que la france te donne toi tu me
rends en disant nique la france non je
suis trompé les revenus pour excuser
mais en fait la dent ce match parce que
est ce qu'il y avait le maroc ou
l'algérie qui jouait non non alors
pourquoi est-ce que du coup tu as dû
parler du maroc et de l'algérie
d'accord non mais je suis d'accord mais
en fait en france tu dis nique la france
eux puis ensuite tu dis vive d'autres
pays c'était origines mais je veux dire
si tu as choisi la france c'est bien
parce que tu as voulu quitter ton pays
pour venir en france et si tulle m et si
tu la respectes comme tu dis tu as pas
le droit de dire vivre tu apprendras
dernier que la française sipa biaggi
touché toute la france dont la france
ouais normand moi j'ai pas de droit je
dis ça et pourquoi tu l'as dit je lui
dis c'est trop mais moi je rentre stade
g samedi par le stade de france et je
savais même pas comment il est sorti si
tu rentres dans le stade de france qui
dit aviv la france je suis trop content
dit oui je les dis bien mais avant tout
je
tiens à maintenir que la france ça veut
dire ah bah c'est beau la france voilà
je suis en france masqué en france en
france on est des nul voila basée à
gilles segris c'est vrai que l'effet des
paroles est dévastateur bien sûr pour
nous qui essayons de défendre les les
quartiers les choses polling qui s'y
passe merci messieurs c'est vrai que je
trouve que vos excuses vous devriez
l'ailé les reformuler vraiment parce que
honnêtement moi je trouve que le
lynchage que vous subissez c'est
scandaleux je suis de votre côté mais
pour des gens comme nous vous entendre
dire ça ça fout tout en l'air un seul
remise aux parents quoi sur une enfance
ont traversé la méditerranée ils ont été
accueillis comme il se nomme madame nos
parents
comme se doit ils ont plus de travail et
ils ont pu nous éduquer alors ne pas
dire qu'il ya fraude aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce jeune homme là c'est une
erreur qui ne refera plus car c'est un
impact considérable dans son cercle
familial ça a un impact considérable
dans son travail et c'est normalement
c'est normal les gens qu'on voit il n'a
pas sauvé d'agréger les gens consulter
la grille tous ces gens là font marche
arrière on fait marche arrière par
rapport à ce qu'on essaye nous de faire
un jeu faire passer comme message ici de
dire qu'elle sait pas parce que tu viens
de saint-nic n'étais pas doué c'est pas
parce que t'as pas fait d'études que
t'es pas doué on peut donner des chances
avec des discours comme ça un patron
d'entreprise il va dire ils veulent
longtemps dire nique la france et
l'autre derrière qui fait ses trucs de
pistolet 10 m à ces mecs là j'en veux
pas j'en veux pas moi c'est ça le tort
qu'il fait mais c'est pourquoi je dis le
lin je sais ça damas
non mais il a dit une connerie mais ça
me choque qu'on lynche publiquement un
jeune qui a mis mouskouri sur ce match
est une personnalité publique disent des
conneries il y en a plein un jeune qui
fait un signe de pistolets ça veut pas
dire je vais tirer ce coup là c'est un
jeune d'origine maghrébine donc ça veut
dire je vais tirer sur tout le monde
suite à la
menace semble loin des jeunes c'est très
bien épaulé en cela
il ya des menaces de marée regardez les
tweets ca ya trop d'arabes en france on
rentre ici c'est dégueulasse donc je te
pose à m'accorder dit une connerie s'est
excusé arrêter tu veux quelque chose
même à ton frère là qui te regardent
peut-être où tous les atouts les
français qui nous regardent tous ont été
choqués et voilà et qu'est ce que tu
aurais quelque chose à leur dire ce soir
jeudi excuse tout le monde j'ai pas fait
exprès non moi j'ai fais pas ça
ce que c'est ce que je sais pas après à
ton frère tu lui dirais quoi qui veut
pas de parler mon frère ça fait une
semaine ne venez pas me parler avec moi
[Musique]
les chiffres ont parlé de diam's et je
vous disais est ce que vous êtes choqués
par les critiques contre elle remettez
vos titres bancaires juste avant dans le
documentaire diam's coup en larmes
lorsqu'elle évoque l'épisode de paris
match en 2009 qui avait dévoilé des
photos d'elle la montrant à la sortie
d'une mosquée regardez ça ce qui m'a
vendu le triste parce qu'il ya la colère
contre le fait qu'on me voilà un truc
intimes de ma vie ça c'est clair mais ça
c'est gérable moi c'était vraiment par
rapport aux gens qui m'aiment et je
savais qu'ils allaient
comme brise et l'amour qu'ils avaient
entre moi et le public
c'est vraiment faibles j'ai très choquée
parce que ce qu'on lui reproche c'est de
porter le voile d'être musulmane est de
faire du prosélytisme
or elle ne le fait jamais elle raconte
son histoire parce que comme l explique
son histoire allait lui être volées elle
parle d'une manière linéaire elle ne
s'apitoie pas sur elle même je trouve
son interview le documentaire très bien
et je ne comprends absolument pas ses
critiques si quelqu'un allait faire une
retraite dans un monastère à catholique
dans un monastère on dirait c'est
formidable parce qu'elle porte le voile
en la critique c'est absurde alors elle
parle aussi de ses souffrances
psychologiques elle a également évoqué
son internement ni aux cliniques
psychiatriques en 2008 et je me souviens
depuis la clinique et bungert commence à
me faire du mal en fait
et quand les infirmières et les gens
restent confus ça ils ont dit non ça y
est un stop et la balle à une main et un
hibou est un aimant quand je dis mon et
un ans et qui m'ont donné plein de cash
et voilà si c'est pas sous le coup de la
loi on a droit de critiquer sa prise de
parole on voit là je trouve que on a
droit est ce que je veux dire c'est que
sa religion et sa foi on a le droit de
le critiquer au même titre que manon
religions et la laïcité il ya passé pas
plus sacrées diam's que moi qui ne suis
pas religieuse déjà donc ça c'est la
première chose et ensuite tu disais
gilles qu' il n'y a pas de prosélytisme
il ya eu quand même dans dans son
discours quelque chose comme la musique
ses péchés elle a quand même une
pratique de l'islam qui moi à titre
personnel si tu veux moi ça m'a fait ce
qui est absolument ce qu'elle veut de sa
vie qui moi pas neutres ou mais
j'aimerais peut-être pas que moi ma
fille elle entendre par exemple que la
musique c'est péché ou j'aimerais
j'aimerais pas qu'on dise aujourd'hui
comme on le dit beaucoup qu'elle est
repenti et voilée elle a été sauvée par
l'islam j'ai pas si vous vous rendez
compte dans ce qu'elle dit l'islam la
sauver lectra géraldine non mais je le
cite l'islam m'a sauvé à trouver la paix
intérieure grâce à l'islam accès de quoi
je trouve ça beau la manière dont elle
parle de religion et encore une fois je
trouve ça aucun prosélytisme quand elle
je crois musique ses péchés tu trouves
ça commente non mais elle dit
qu'aujourd'hui il ne se reconnaît plus
dans ce mois dernier remet en jeu à la
31e sourates du coran qui proscrit la
musique voilà c'est pour ça qu'elle a
préféré arrêter une fois qu'elle a été
découverte voile et à son insu c'est
pour ça mais elle a pris la décision
d'arrêter mais elle avait six mois je
trouve moi je trouve qu'elle est moi je
trouve qu'elle est elle est inattaquable
diabolique
elle a pris la décision elle a été au
bout de sa décision et moi je trouve ça
très bien moi je sais ma génération donc
ça me touche pour moi diam's et si on
veut
c'est quoi ces excès charles aznavour
alors oui donc moi ça me touche vraiment
pour moi diam's à les intouchables c'est
pas parce que on est connu on tire on
dit qu'un truc public que ça va
spécialement toucher nos enfants les
enfants ils ont eu des parents pour
l'éducation silva les éduquer d'une
certaine manière bas c'est leur problème
si diam's l envie de dire que la musique
c'est interdit moi ça me dérange pas
qu'elle le dise si elle le pense
profondément
chacun a le droit de penser ce qu'il
veut il que c'est un modèle pour les
jeunes c'est un modèle mais les jeunes
sont pas te bay et au caire ils ont des
parents si ça dérange les parents la
musique est proscrit bah pourquoi pas
après moi ce que j'aurais aimé c'est
qu'elle le dise plus tôt voilà nous on
aurait aimé plus d'explications plus tôt
alors on est hyper content qu'elle le
fasse si tardivement et c'est son choix
mais moi j'aurais même aimé aimer
quelqu'un en parle plutôt ouais bah
presse à calcutta grille critiqué par
les médias
la brave ivre avant de se retirer
beaucoup parlent en tant que femme bien
sûr qu'est ce qui dérange pas se mentir
c'est qu'elle ait choisi de se tourner
d'un bébé relais sainte anne marie qui
avait fait l'église est alors effet
l'église quand tu rentres au couvent que
vient curé tueur nord la durée exacte en
culture renoncer à l'argent tu reviens
d'un voyage
dans la religion a permis de vivre mieux
m
qu'est ce que je te dis c'est mal de se
retourner pour les jours même si la bêta
si elle avait mis aujourd'hui vont alors
on en regardant les sardes religion tu
vas bien que la religion mais oui mais
ça on est d'accord je trouve une alim
que tu fais un mauvais procès parce que
cette on voit bien sur les réseaux
sociaux elle est attendue tout le temps
après par lire sur elle pourrait faire
du prosélytisme vraiment où on va suivre
est comme un guide spirituel elle ne le
fait pas quand elle répond à des
questions c'est vraiment à dose
homéopathique
elle a préféré faire ce documentaire
elle-même justement pour qu'on ne fausse
pas ses propos mais franchement on peut
pas dire qu'elle se montrer qu'elle fait
du prosélytisme c'est un faux procès là
je trouve
[Musique]
cas au stade de farce honte ce week-end
la presse étrangère n'a pas épargné la
france et sa gestion de la sécurité aux
abords du stade de france samedi soir la
finale de la ligue des champions
opposant liverpool au real de madrid va
connaître en minutes de retard le coup
d'envoi tomas devrait pas avoir lieu
avant 21h30 6 à l'extérieur des scènes
terribles de désordre et de débordements
qui m'ont très vite faire le tour du
monde
j'aurais convoi cette vidéo qui a
énormément tourné avec jordi et moi
quand j'arrive au stade de france voilà
ce qu'ont expliqué aux gens pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est vrai que c'est ça
explique aussi beaucoup de choses de ce
qui s'est passé après regarde
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que le truc ne marchait pas
en fait pourquoi parce que comme eu
énormément de phobies ça se bloque un
moment c'est sa journée c'est exactement
donc il y avait il y avait un il y avait
vraiment une foule incroyable parce que
à moins que tellement de faux billets
qui sont passées que la machine le
tourniquet se bloque donc forcément
voilà c'est ce n'était plus possible de
passer par les passe en dessous et c'est
jordi gentiment qui me dit papa sans
doute parce qu'il voyait plus en plus de
gens arrivent et pour faire des selphy
voilà eric donc il va dit passe en
dessous comme ça au moins jack ira plus
vite c'est c'était d'ailleurs la bonne
solution en reste puisque justement il y
avait beaucoup de monde derrière qui
pousse et je me suis dit directement tu
étais là donc je me suis dit vas-y en
priorité toi quand même puisque tu es
une personnalité publique donc je me
suis dit vas-y tu vas passer à normand
plus ça parce que comme tu voyais qu'il
ya beaucoup de tentations tout avait
passé sans oublier aussi ce qu'on voit
justement ouais alors c'est vrai que
c'est une rigolade parce que il ya quand
même des gars qui sont dit que
j'arrêtais aller au stade de france sans
billes avec il ya quand même des
journalistes c'est quand même des jeans
non mais franchement qui se sont dits
hanouna et s'est mis à prendre la
voiture samedi soir il va aller au stade
de france pour voir karim benzema ce
qu'ils savent qu ici il va appeler car
et une barbe les personnes il va y aller
c'est retransmis sur canal+ en fait mon
choix c'est quand même là on est dans le
mot est choisi il va prendre sa voiture
et va dire je vais aller fraudé au stade
de france mais les gars c'est quand même
des génies cia ils ont même fait des
articles très sérieux pour savoir si
j'étais bien passée sous un tourniquet
si j'avais des billets si j'avais fait
passer des gens regardent et lci les
vérificateurs digressions oui cyril
hanouna est bien passé sous une barrière
au stade de france ap regarder après
après regardez c'est pas fini donc les
vrais ligue des champions non si les
régionales a pas forcé le passage pour
le stade de france parce qu'ils ont
vérifié donc c'est une barque à
incroyable je veux dire que là c'était
drôle stats ne sont pas omettre les
vidéos voici les deux premières images
je suis là c'était dans le stade ouais
les les vidéos d'après son fils est mort
c'est pas dans le stade c'est de près
filtrage qu'ils ont qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont sauté c'est à dire c'est quoi
en fait c'est à dire que da par exemple
ça c'est pas dans le stade ça c'est le
pré filtre à charbon du stade d'accord
oui ça va c'est en dehors du sat aussi
ouais en fait il y avait il ya le stade
il ya un après filtrage et par rapport
aux faux billets les anglais ils ont
racheté la balle est faux billets arrivé
ici savait pas si des faux billets à un
certain moment il ya une cohue donc là
ils ont commencé à forcer et donc après
les dérives dont ils ont profité donc là
eu de la place étaient dans le stade
mais les deux images d'après c'était pas
dans le stade donc il y avait plus de
bordel haut niveau au niveau des
supporters de liverpool donc au niveau
du prix filtrage avec les faux billets
un moment on a ils ont réussi à
contrôler et à un moment il va notamment
qu'il ya beaucoup de billets et moi je
confirme c'est pas confirmé mais il y
avait au moins 20 à 40 me de faux
billets donc là ça commençait à faire là
camus et puis après ils sont rentrés
samedi j'étais avec les supporters
anglais dans le rer d il se montrait ils
se montraient leur billet à 490 euros
690 euros valeur faciale entre eux ils
se disaient ses défauts on va parler la
fan zone on va aller au stade de france
ils sont arrivés à 30 milles sans billet
il ya une mafia à lillers zèle des
combats une mafia arrêté il ya une mafia
à liverpool industrielle du faux billets
il avait demandé des billets papier pour
les falsifier la question au tessin en
scène parmi le sujet a dominé ça arrive
en france pour payer le poly energy star
et celle à venir à savoir qu'il n'y a
pas cinq heures du vainqueur il n'y a
pas ce à quoi
daniel riolo qui a ciblé les bandes des
cités et migros a énormément fait parler
regarde personne n'a anticipé est ce qui
a fait que cette soirée est devenue un
cauchemar à savoir que ce mélange entre
les bandes des cités de saint-denis et
les migrants de porte de la chapelle se
mélangent l'a d'ailleurs dans le rapport
il ya 400 500 personnes en mai n'est
licite et beaucoup plus sûrs si beaucoup
plus et ça a donné cet amalgame qui est
venu mais mais faire des ravages dans
les populations de supporters on a pu en
voir beaucoup de supporters espagnols
dans les témoignages gens recommenceront
recevoir quelques-uns match moi ce qui
m'énerve c'est que il ya des dizaines de
milliers d'anglais qui excusez moi
l'expression foutent le bordel au stade
de france on frôle des morts et des
blessés et on tape sur un 30 jeunes de
saint denis potentiellement qui est
facile on a déshabillé riolo selon
daniel riolo et monsieur tout reste
pareil on tape mais daniel je l'écouté
c'est pas du tout bien ce qu'il a dit on
tape sur des jeunes de saint denis qui
effectivement tenus concernant bien de
ça nous reprocher je reproche à daniel
d'avoir ciblé l'avoir fait de la
politique et d'avoir ciblé des jeunes de
santé de la politique pensée mort scalp
les hooligans noirs ou arabes de des
quartiers différents moyens et des
quartiers de saint nic alors que ces
jeunes là qui n'ont pas de billets
effectivement ils ont envie de voir le
match il faut une connerie mais c est le
problème n'était pas là force est pas un
problème d'immigration c'est pas un
problème de saint denis c'est un
problème d'anglais qui sont venus
dévasté ruiner une finale donc que
daniel daniel riolo là je suis désolé
monsieur torres de pareilles c'est
totalement faux ce que vous avez un
ordinateur
oui ça vient de tomber le footballeur
espagnol gerard piqué n'aime pas que
courir en chaussettes dans le sable mais
aussi voir d'autres nana en douce sauf
que shakira l'a bien grillées et du coup
lui a dit ciao gerard piqué et shakira
débat sous le thème ou singstar et coûté
un peu cher pour les enfants et ensemble
fidélité ça peut coûter très très cher à
la série ils sont pas mariés
est immensément riche parce qu'à son
salaire de footballeur il a aussi une
société qui s'appelle causse moi qui
gère d'état l'événement sportif donc ça
va lui coûter très cher elle est partie
à ibiza avec les deux enfants et on dit
que ça fait plusieurs mois en fait
qu'ils sont plus vraiment ensemble et
lui il sort toutes les nuits ce qu'elle
n'a pas supporté les jeunes de bara tall
a été peut-être boulanger
tu vois tu vois la mer voilà ça peut
arriver partout même dans les coupes et
ça s'est vu c'est un couple et ça
arrivera confiance en
question la confiance engrangée il ça
peut arriver de son côté comme du mien
ya pas deux
[Musique]
on
pense forcément que ça arrive que chez
la personne a médiatisé du couple où la
personne plus jeune ou la personne là
mais non ça peut arriver partout mois la
voilà ça sert à rien d'attendre oui mais
symbolique et s'aimer se surprendre
parce que sinon ça c'est l'amorcé nous
surprendre si réel comment doivent être
âgés ou le surprendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]